I'm going to need us as a collective
community of critical thinkers to think
very carefully about what I am about to
report to you and it relates to an
interview that Donald Trump gave to
Reuters yesterday and in this interview
Donald Trump said that he's worried that
what he says to robert muller if he
agrees to be interviewed by robert
muller or his investigators as part of
this Trump Russia investigation Trump
believes that what he says to Muller
would be used to bring perjury charges
against him in that investigation now
let's look at the wording that Donald
Trump used in the interview when he said
this because this is sort of the
foundation upon which our analysis will
be built Trump said quote yesterday so
if I say something and he Comey
says something else and it's my word
against his and he's best friends with
Muller so Muller might say well I
believe Comey and even if I'm telling
the truth
that makes me a liar that's no good so
the easy reading of this is hey if you
don't want to be charged with perjury
don't lie to investigators federal
agents period the argument that Trump
and his lawyers are making and have been
making is that Donald Trump's statements
will be unfairly used to charge him with
perjury meaning merely at the discovery
of any discrepancy with what another
witness has said Trump will be unfairly
charged with perjury so there's two
really important elements to analyze
here once is this concept of a perjury
trap and then the other is that Trump is
effectively pleading the fifth here I
want to talk more about perjury trap
because this is the the misinformation
around that has gotten so ridiculous
that we've got to pick it apart but
let's start with the pleading the fifth
thing here Donald Trump is not literally
pleading the fifth which lets you not
testify against yourself in order to
avoid self-incrimination but what Trump
is doing is effectively it's like a de
facto pleading the fifth Trump is
worried that his statements will be self
incriminating fairly or unfairly Trump
would say unfairly so Trump is
considering not giving statements to
Robert Mulder now Trump has said time
and again that
innocent people don't plead the fifth
remember this as just one example
sheis people take you in the Fifth
Amendment for people plus the guy who
illegally did the server you know he put
in the illegal server so there are five
people taking the fifth amendment like
you see on the mob right you see the mob
takes of it if you're innocent why you
taking the fifth amendment yeah so there
are many of these I won't play them all
I won't show you all the tweets it's
been applied to Hillary Clinton two
staffers two people in Trump's business
past all sorts of people that Trump has
said if you're innocent you don't plead
the fifth
so Trump once again if you aren't guilty
when law enforcement wants to talk to
you you talk to them and Trump is
violating his own standard here but the
reason why he would say he's violating
it is because here there is this unfair
desire to set a perjury trap against
Trump let's break this down first of all
what is perjury perjury is when you
willfully tell an untruth in a court or
investigation under oath this can
include to a grand jury this can include
to investigators perjury is the willful
telling of untruths you're not going to
be charged with perjury if your comments
because of lack of recollection or lack
of specificity or lack of detail simply
don't align with what another witness
said because perjury is the willful
telling of lies and perjury convictions
are difficult to get because it's tough
to figure out legally speaking or to
prove legally speaking that someone was
willfully telling lies so Trump's
framing that any accidental or
coincidental inaccuracies or conflicts
with what for example James Comey has
told Robert Muller will get him charged
with perjury are ridiculous at their
face because perjury convictions are
really difficult to get and prosecutors
aren't going to just willy-nilly try to
get soft perjury charges in this way but
the most important part of this is not
the definition of perjury which again
means the willful telling of untruths a
perjury trap is a real thing but it's
prosecutorial misconduct prosecutors get
in trouble for setting perjury traps
even though it happens in
we rarely and there is a definition for
what it means to set a perjury trap a
perjury trap is when you call a witness
in to testify without any real suspicion
that the person has already committed
crimes solely with the intent of getting
them to lie under oath to make that the
one and only crime that you charge them
with perjury traps almost never happen
at the federal level and in fact no US
federal court has ever accepted a motion
to dismiss because of claimed perjury
traps period okay
we already know that Mulder's team has
been talking to everybody from Trump's
personal lawyer Michael Cohen to White
House lawyer done began to everybody in
between about actions taken by Trump
that might constitute obstruction of
justice by definition that already means
the perjury trap accusation would be
bogus if Trump perjures himself it is
not a trap set without any reason to
think Trump may have already committed
other crimes Trump is part of this
because he may have committed other
crimes perjury traps are when you have
nothing on somebody and you want to get
them to perjure themselves it simply
doesn't apply here yeah it is bogus but
it's what the Trump lawyers have to go
with this has to be their strategy
because Trump is a pathological liar I
mean he just speaks that way he speaks
in hyperbole so there's no way he could
go into an interview with robert muller
and not come out of it having told
10-plus live and it's not even the
hyperbole it's that he thinks he's
smarter than everybody else and they
won't be able to figure out whether he's
lying and unfortunately even though I'm
telling you don't fall for the perjury
trap nonsense and there are some other
journalists telling you don't fall for
the perjury trap nonsense Rudy Giuliani
is doing a really good job of spreading
the nonsense and people are starting to
buy it they are starting to believe that
a perjury trap is being set for Donald
Trump here when it literally does not
apply to the circumstances by the way
also notable Trump said in the same
interview with Reuters that if he wanted
to he could take over the Moller
investigation but he's choosing not to
Trump said quote I can go in and I could
do whatever I could run it if I want but
I decided to stay out I'm totally
allowed to be involved if I wanted to be
so far I haven't chosen to be involved
I'll stay out legally I mean who knows
if that's the case I don't I'm
run out from the perjury trap debunking
that I don't even have the energy to get
into that part he wants the Russian
officials to also investigate their own
meddlings yeah we can have Trump and the
Russians investigate Trump Russia
they'll be great Putin made an
incredible offer which is that Trump can
partner with Russians and they together
can investigate
I guess themselves because they are the
ones at this point suspected of the
wrongdoing